chapter that has been assigned this week
was originally two chapters one on the
Mongols and the West the younger the
other on the Mongols and the East
this made the Mongols pretty much the
only people in world history who were
granted two chapters the Romans didn't
get two chapters the maybe the British
get a couple of chapters but by and
large this was a an outgrowth of the
idea in world history that that the
Mongols have been not only studied from
a particular and unfavorable point of
view in an unwarranted fashion but also
that they did something that was of
extraordinary importance namely creating
a land link across Eurasia between
peoples of the East peoples of the West
and to some degree peoples of the south
so the Mongols have been largely
rehabilitated it's hard to think of a
people less worthy imitation
in the sense that they really did kill
an awful lot of people and I can't quite
see us you know at some future date
saying you know hit there wasn't really
so bad yeah you killed a lot of people
but just think of his vision for Europe
you know but with the Mongols nobody
denies the stories although it's often
believed that they are exaggerated you
know where you take all the people in
the city and you divide them by the
number of people in your army and you've
got let's say ten and so you assign ten
people per soldier to kill because that
way you can efficiently kill everybody
and then you come back two or three days
later to find everyone who has hit it
out in the ruins or you know kill the
cats and dogs and so forth these stories
are so so lurid and so extreme so
focused on cities you know the
depopulation of the countryside never
just doesn't have as much publicity as
killing everybody in the city the the
thought that I have pressed on you at
least from the Middle Eastern
perspective that the areas that the
Mongols entered in the Middle East were
already in a semi ruined and the
populated state has not yet been you
know integrated into world history in
general but I think eventually it will
because I think it's it's fairly clear
that this was to some degree true and
perhaps true of the territories of Kiev
and Russia and some other some other
lands that became prey to the Mongols
because
they have already entered into times of
troubles and political and economic
sometimes demographic disorder but be
that as it may you have this amazing
phenomenon of these enormous lis
destructive invasions carried out by or
at the behest of the leaders of pastoral
tribes of Mongolia emerging as a great
moment in history is something that you
really have to to ask questions about is
there something about the Mongol
experience that goes beyond simply the
the narrative but I don't know but let
me just suggest one thing or a couple of
things one of them is that in some ways
the Mongols seem to prefigure modernity
how they are not religiously motivated
they are people who operate from a what
we the modern times call a realpolitik
they look at the political situation
they take advantage of it they create
new realities but they don't do it in
the service either of a religion or of a
particular ideology or even for that
matter of a particular culture rather
they bring into their orbit into their
army but also into their their entire
Imperial structure people of many
different ethnicities many different
Palance many different languages many
religions members of the ruling family
of the family of jenga's khan belonged
to different religions and seemed to
have had no conflict at least in the
central lands based on the question of
religion so they appear to be kind of a
modern state where talented people can
rise even if they are not part of the
ruling family or part of a hereditary
aristocracy simply because they are
really good at what they do another
aspect that is appealing to some
historians is the fact that they they
like to organize things in decimal
fashion so that you would have units of
a hundred units of a thousand units of
ten thousand and so forth that you would
have instead of having the tribe or the
the chieftain ship or something kind of
funky and primitive like that'd be your
organizing principle you had what
appears to be a rational principle you
know not only did you have this decimal
organization but it carried over into
the tax area where you would charge a
certain area with supporting a certain
decile of of warriors
they appeal to some people because of a
of a hardiness that allows them
seemingly to travel unlimited distances
and go into battle and prevail against
enemies that are on home turf and are
better armed and more more deeply
inspired to win the battle and the
Mongols win anyway in other words you
have again the temptation is to think
blitzkrieg the idea of of invincibility
these are kind of modern thoughts things
that will perhaps resonate more with the
Napoleonic period than with Hitler's
Germany although you could argue that
there's more of an ideology of Napoleon
certainly he did not favor any
particular religion and there was pretty
much an opening to talent in his empire
so that's one one way to look at it but
I think has appealed to some world
asourian's another way is this question
of of connecting across Eurasia and what
has been particularly appealing is that
the linkage across Eurasia is being
carried out by an Asian people not by
Europeans and it is a kind of analog for
the for the world exploration by see
that the Europeans undertake a century
and a half later in other words you have
this nice balance the Europeans
you know spread around the world and
bring people into contact by creating
maritime empires the Mongols spread my
land and bring people into contact
through a throw land empire for people
who believe that world history is in its
essence of the story of people's coming
into contact and getting to know each
other better and better the mongol
period is is wonderful because it not
only produces the reality of this kind
of translation contact but it produces a
large number of narratives and from a
historical point of view you know one
one travel account is worthy you know
three chronicles which is worth 100
quantitative series i mean it's you know
there's just a note to be able to talk
about you know somebody who went
someplace and saw something so forth has
just been very very
riveting for historians there have been
questions about some of these chronicles
Marco Polo for example I myself have had
great questions about William a rubric
and I was wrong
William of rubric was a person who
traveled out to the clergyman traveled
out to the Mongol capital and karakorum
and wrote a very influential account of
the Mongols and then it he says things
about wheel transport that simply made
no sense at all he said well no there
was a vehicle that was 30 feet wide and
it was pulled by 22 oxen in two lines 11
and the first line going across and 11
in the 11 in front and I read that I
thought how do you how do you do that
how do you get those oxen to pull at the
same time how do you harness them and
how do you find a axle that's 30 feet
long and how much would it weigh and how
much how big would the house have to be
the top of it and I decided will you're
really over brick was pulling the
collective European leg and then
recently I ran across a stroll painting
from the shortly after the Mongol
dynasty in China that act it's a Chinese
scroll painting that actually shows a
vehicle drawn by 22 horses lined you
know arranged in exactly the same way
and just as in William of Rubik account
there is no sign of a driver now it may
be that the Chinese artist red william
of rubric but that's unlikely because he
wrote in lab when the chinese generally
didn't have access to latin text but
but the thing is some of the things that
seem so fantastic and in this case to me
unbelievable in the account slop Mongols
seem in fact to have been true and that
that is is quite intriguing because you
it makes you wonder where it all began
how did this culture come into being
there is of course the historical rule
that causation recedes to the point of
least valid so that if you have ruled
out every other explanation of where of
how something came about you look for
the most obscure place that you know
nothing about and you say it must have
happened there and this has been the
great help of historians of Arabia and
Central Asia where they can kind of
assume unspecified tribal processes and
cultural amalgams that lead to great
conquering moments whether it's the
Arabs or before them the arameans or
whether it's the Mongols are before them
the Huns alishan knew but the fact of
the matter is we simply don't know very
much about about the roots of this whole
Mongol phenomenon I'm what I'm going to
take up today and again on Thursday is
actually going to address something a
little bit different and this is the the
narrative strategy that we adopted in
our book
that looked at the Mongols as a as a
stimulus that spurred various responses
among various peoples in different parts
on different fringes of the Mongol of
the Mongol Empire sort of the West
you have the Russians and Lithuanians
the Mamluks in Egypt and the Ottomans
eventually you might even include the
founders of the Bogle dynasty in India
in the east you have particularly the
reaction in China the rise of the Ming
Dynasty and the the question of Japan a
country that experienced two Mongol
invasions and remained unconquered but
was changed because the experience when
you take a an entity of something and
you say what's interesting about it is
the responses to it you are to some
degree diminishing the originality or
the intent or the the agency of the
people who are doing the reacting you're
saying well they wouldn't have acted
this way had it not been for this this
event and therefore the Mongol conquests
in the 13th century are portrayed as
being important because of what they set
in motion among peoples who may came in
contact with and not simply for what
they did in their own domains to say
this is to create a kind of impression
of similarity at the Lithuanian Zhan the
Russians and the Ottoman Turks and the
Mamluks in Egypt are similar because
responding to the mongols the same way
that perhaps the Koreans and the Chinese
of the Japanese have a certain
similarity in their responses to the
Mongols this is very different for
example from how we how we treated and
how most historians treat something like
the Roman Empire in other words the
Roman Empire they say let us tell the
story of the Empire itself you know a
small agrarian kingdom rises to become a
powerful Republic
if metamorphoses into an empire it
becomes a continent spamed a expanding
entity and let us follow that story from
the kings of Rome down through the
heyday of the Roman Empire down to its
collapse in the fifth century in the
West and somewhat later in the East and
then you say well ok the Roman Empire
had an impact because we have Romance
languages so it had an impact upon the
Spaniards in the French and the
Romanians and it had an impact upon you
know the people of the East or the
people in Africa but the center of the
story really is the narrative of the
Empire itself and you don't very often
find a historian who will say let us
compare oh the evolution of berber
tribal power in africa with the
evolution of Germanic tribal power in
the north of Europe seeing Rome as the
stimulus and this is the response so
with the Mongol Empire where the where
the central narrative is available but
not really given very much I would say
people are interested in Roman empires
emperors are not very interested in in
bondo emperors other than jenga's han
himself
there is a central narrative but what
we're urging in our book and in other
works you have a similar strategy is to
look at how you compare the responses I
think it probably would be fair to say
that the responses have more difference
than similarity and that if you were to
take these responses as separate
narratives you might have a more useful
grounding for writing about the later
history one of the common features that
you have however when you take the
Mongol experience as a stimulus to which
various peoples respond is that you have
a the question of fear there are a
couple of books that have been written
on the history of fear and you look at
them and and they tend to look at fear
in a kind of undifferentiated way that
to say you're curious what people are
afraid of disease or when they're afraid
of an invasion or whether they're in
afraid of Oh
modernity you know Luddite opposition to
machines or something like that but with
the Mongols you have the idea that fear
becomes an instrument of political
leverage and that the people who deploy
that instrument do it consciously and
they do it for four particular ends
the example I want to take is the
example of the Mamluks in Egypt and
Syria we know much more about them than
we do about either the early Ottomans or
the Russians or the Lithuanian the
Mamluks have been fairly massively
studied particularly in the last thirty
years or so for a very long time what we
knew about the Mongols in the Middle
East where they had come on two
occasions first in the period 1218 to
1221 dirge Angus Khan himself where they
brought most of Iran under Mongol rule
and the second time in the 12 50s
culminating in the destruction of the
city of Baghdad and the death of the
last of acid Calif fare under Genghis
Khan's grandson Hulagu what we have
known about the Mongols has come from
two sources first the narratives of the
Mongol conquests written by people who
worked for the Mongols particularly
Persian historians who were in the
employ of the of the Mongol Hans and who
wrote probably the most horrific tales
now many of the classic destruction
stories that tell us about the Mongol
onslaught come from Persian historians
who are writing for the Mongols
why they're doing this it is not
entirely clear if there are times when
conquerors relish the destruction that
they bring about or the the depredations
the killing that comes about at their
design the classic model of this are the
old Assyrian Emperor's back before 500
BC where we have these magnificent bow
reliefs now largely in the British
Museum showing the sacking of cities and
the killing of captives but you get a
lot of it in Egyptian art as well and as
a presume that this is to glorify the
ruler because the ruler is a presence
and all of this in the mongol narratives
the the ruler is not that that riveting
a presence at least not in terms of
ordering something in other words you
don't see the ruler portrayed as sort of
personally going and conquering it's
it's more a modern type of narrative
well there's an army there's a
bureaucracy there are orders given or
things that happen and everybody dies so
it doesn't quite fit the Akkadian
Imperial bottle it's often been argued
that the purpose of these narratives or
one of the purposes was to enhance fear
to to make it so that a ruling minority
and certainly the Mongols wherever they
were outside of Central Asia proper
represented a very small
rulers ruling class to make it so that
nobody would rebel against the Mongols
because they had heard the stories of
what would happen if they did in other
words using fear for propaganda purposes
particularly in cities that had to be
used as administrative administrative
centers so the fact that these
narratives are rich and mostly in
Persian considering that the Mongols
didn't read Persian for the most part
they weren't being written to be read by
the Mongols we don't actually have any
Chronicle in Mongolian language other
than the so-called secret history of the
Mongols which is the story of Timon gems
rise to power and has becoming the
historical figure of jenga's Khan so
they're not being written at the behest
of Mongol rulers for the edification of
of the Mongols but presumably for the
edification of the people whom the
Mongols have have achieved dominion over
and this supports the idea that this
this is kind of propaganda writing does
that mean that the massacres did not
occur at one time I kind of thought that
that maybe a lot of this is just really
really overwritten and I found that
picture of the 22 oxen in in the city
that I did research on for my doctoral
dissertation there which was once a huge
city the city of Nishapur one hundred to
two hundred thousand people at its peak
around one thousand the city had fallen
by about 80 percent in population
judging from the settled from the area
of settlement by they'll say by 1150 the
Mongols come through some 70 years later
the report of the destruction of the
city is that everything in the city was
leveled that there were no buildings
left standing and when I look at aerial
photographs of the medieval city that
was abandoned for a variety of reasons
in the course of the 1100s and late
perhaps late 1000s I can see evidence of
all sorts of buried structures it was
very clear that this was a city that was
simply abandoned while it was largely
intact and over the centuries wind had
deposited dust and covered it to a depth
around 20 feet or so but then I'd look
over at the walled area that surrounded
the portion of the city that was
destroyed by the Mongols and there are
no ruins it is appears to be a
completely flat surface with no
undulation or hum --ax indicating some
buried structure so I thought well maybe
the Mongols really did destroy
everything it's it's hard to know we
haven't really tried a sort of test of
that of that sort of narrative but
anyway that's one of the sources the
other source in a sense is more
interesting because it consists of works
in Arabic written by people who are not
conquered by the Mongols and this is
where the question of of fear comes in
Arabic readers were told that the
Mongols had a law code known as the
Yassa just as the Muslims had a law code
known as the Sharia the Yasha was sort
of portrayed as the anti Sharia and it
was said that in the areas where the
Mongols conquered that the Yassa
replaced the good Muslim law of the
Sharia in the same way that the Sharia
has replaced American law in dear bird
and some non-existent town in Oklahoma
and very much in the same way that is to
say there was never any particular
evidence that the ASSA had replaced the
Sharia except that it was stated in
these Arabic sources so what did the
ASSA consist of well there's there's not
a lot of detail given but there are some
details the person who who sort of onion
you know unpacked the the notion of the
Yasha was David I alone a very very
distinguished Israeli scholar of last
generation gave terrible lectures but he
was really a very good scholar and he
wrote two articles I believe they were
in studio Islamic ax about what was the
awesome and in it he told the stories as
they were told in Arabic sources of a
mammoth period and then he looked into
into the substance of them it's fairly
clear that the Arabic sources were
intended to terrify Muslims about the
Mongols there are various instances the
only one that really sticks well in my
mind
is the whole question of meet the Koran
prohibits the eating of meat that has
blood in it it's a reason all of your
middle-eastern friends always ask for
well done when they order a steak the
only people in the world while you order
things well done for the Mongols it
seems it is said that the quality of the
meat is improved by having the blood in
the meat so what Muslims would do would
be to cut the throat of an animal and
hang it up for the blood to the heart is
still beating and allow the blood to be
pumped out so that you get rid of the
blood and then in in halal butchering or
kosher butchering you have meat that
doesn't have any blood in it what the
Muslims were told was that for the
Mongols and I can't verify this
firsthand I have no idea actually how
the Mongols killed animals but what they
were told was that the Mongols would cut
into the abdomen and reach in and
squeeze the heart so that the animal
would die but the blood would not be
pumped out because there would be no
more pumping of the heart now first this
was really disgusting but it also let
people think well if you live in the
lands of the Mongols you know you're
doomed to be a vegan I suppose maybe
that's the way they look at it but but
all the meat you know you'll be like the
Sharia requires that you have halal
butchering the yasser requires a Gaza
butchering and Muslims can't live there
and that was kind of the notion that
Muslims can't live where the Mongols
rule
because the Vyasa is so different from
the Sharia that that Muslim simply
cannot cannot live there there are all
sorts of analogies and later times with
you know where Muslims can live or where
non-muslims to live and so forth what
kind of circumstances we must cope with
but what never seemed to get noted in
the medieval period was that the lands
of the mongols occupied were chock-full
of muslims who were not all vegetarians
and that the mongols themselves
converted to islam or at least in the
western areas in russia and iran they
did making the whole issue moot but the
fear of the mongols was the important
thing here why the fear was so important
gets into the question of the reaction
of people in the Middle East to to the
coming of the Mongols
I'm go back to the you know I mentioned
earlier when I talked about the chapter
on on the rise of Islam that there's a
very awkward from my point of view
awkward break off point breaking off
point in that chapter where you you sort
of stop when the Mongols come and
because we were going to cover that
later on uh namely in this chapter but
the reason it's awkward is because there
is more continuity across this this
invasion moment of the early 1200s then
at first appears so you have a story
that goes back to to the Crusades who
say it started 1095 you have the taking
of Jerusalem by the Crusaders and the
establishment of for small crusading
principalities and then in 1187
Jerusalem is retaken by Saladin by the
time I've mentioned this before by the
time Jerusalem is retaken Iran and Iraq
have fallen into a state of of very
substantial decline bad to say the
population has fallen the agricultural
economy has has dwindled and this is in
my view related very largely to climatic
factors in any event the Iraqis and the
Iranians played comparatively a little
role in the whole saga of the Crusades
when salahuddin our salad and conquered
Jerusalem he sent a letter to the Calif
sang he conquered Jerusalem his troops
to conquer Jerusalem the Caleb sent a
rude letter back saying that your troops
are
to not conquer Jerusalem the troops of
the Calif conquered Jerusalem and they
had this quarrel over who who gets
credit for retaking Jerusalem the next
year there is a you know a fight between
the pilgrims from Syria and pilgrims
from Iraq when they get to Mecca to see
which will be the more prominent pilgrim
group a year or two after that we have
our first inscription in that uses a new
a new title
Hahnemann hunter my meaning the guardian
of the two holy places
Saladin is Guardian to holy places and
in the same inscription he is mentioned
as the master of the of the Haram
al-sharif of the Dome of the rock in
Jerusalem so you have Mecca Medina and
Jerusalem linked in this particular
inscription and they're all put under
the authority of Salah Hadean this title
of mammal harmine subsequently becomes
the most important political attribution
of later Muslim rulers I don't know of
any instance of any caliph being
specifically called the servitor of the
two holy places but up to that point in
time up to the 1190 say it was
understood that the responsibility for
the maintenance of Mecca Medina laid
primarily with the Calif in Baghdad so
now what you'll have basically as a
challenge we're sliding who has a
victorious army under his control is the
master of these holy places and the
Calif does not acknowledge this and it's
seizing a function of the kala faith not
the title of kala but rather a function
of the caliphate and irrigating it to
the the new master of Syria and Egypt
this title is passed on to Salah Hadean
successors in his
this dynastic family the a human family
and the last I you ba'd Falls from well
it dies in the year 1250 during that
period of time that is safe from the
from the late 1100s down to the middle
of the 1200s you have the first
substantial building of services in
Mecca Medina for pilgrims you've got the
first schools you've got the first Sufi
hostels you've got a change in the
taxation rate on pilgrims which had been
fairly punitive before salahuddin and he
cancels the tax in other words there's
every indication that taking care of
pilgrimage business had become a very
important part of the political identity
of Saladin and his family connected to
this was the taking over of Yemen which
was the other end of the Arabian of the
caravan road from Syria down to Mecca
and down to Saudi Arabia so now Egypt
and Syria and Yemen are somewhat
combined those of you who recollect the
history of Gamal Abdel Nasser will be
reminded of when Syria and Egypt joined
together as the United Arab Republic and
then the Egyptian sent a Maxpedition
Airy force to Yemen
to support a revolutionary movement
there with the idea that a Yemen Arab
Republic would be joining with Syria and
Egypt in a you know in a political
linkage prior to Salah Hadean Yemen
really had been a world apart
but now it becomes of interest to Syrian
Egypt remains of interest to Syria in
Egypt down to the present day because of
the pilgrimage and that is the common
interest here
12:50 there is a Fifth Crusade comes to
an end with the defeat of the European
Crusaders the descendant of salahuddin
has killed the ruler of the Sultan who
is ruling in Egypt in Syria Salah Ayub
and the Mamluks the Turkish soldiers who
work for him are fearful that they will
be displaced by the next member of the
Ubud family coming in from Syria to take
over Aselton these were soldiers in a
regiment known as the SOL Mejia after a
Salah Ayub who was the last of the
humans to rule in Cairo these soldiers
said we defeated the Crusaders and we do
not we will not accept the idea that we
should be displaced by saw the group of
Turkish soldiers from Syria so they
killed the incoming Sultan and then
didn't know quite what to do because the
IU buds were legitimate rulers because
they had
achieve great things in defeating the
fosselman's
in egypt and defeating the Crusaders in
Jerusalem they had acquired a legitimacy
by conquest whereas the Mongols were
that their bam Luc's were just soldiers
individuals who came into Egypt and
through slave transactions mostly
Turkish speakers from Central Asia who
were raised in a barracks trained to be
soldiers converted to Islam but they
were they were not really a part of
Egyptian society they were simply a
mercenary not a mercenary but a slave
military core the highest ranking of the
Mamluks were commanders of regiments now
two of these commanders sort of jointly
held power you know after twelve fifty
and represented a potential shift of
power to the Mamluks as a whole it was
complicated by the question of who was
going to marry the widow of the deceased
Sultan and would this person then rule
in the name of an infant son it's a
complicated story the widow's a very
colorful figure named Sushruta daughter
but in the long run of what made the
shift from dynastic legitimacy to
Mameluke rule possible was the Mongols
in the Year 1258 the last Calif was
according to the chronicles rolled up in
a carpet and trampled to death this is
on the principle that you should not
shed the blood of a ruler
and so you you turn him into pot hey
without anyone seeing any blood because
he's kind of a cannelloni operation so
the last Calif is killed in 1258 Baghdad
is what's left of Baghdad after a
century or more of decline is destroyed
and the Mongols move on into Syria then
there is a death in the ruling family
and the Hulagu the grandson of Genghis
Khan is called back to or returns to
karakorum in Mongolia to to take part in
the Family Council called the curl tie
that chooses the next the next Great
Khan he left a army in place in Syria
and that army was like the army that had
been left in Iran after jenga's khan had
gone back to Mongolia it was expected to
hold territory but not to expand
territory it was not and it was a there
to consolidate and hold the position
rather than to extend it
that is the army that the Mamluks went
out to battle in the year 1260 at the
Battle of I in Val Lewton
meaning the spring of Goliath the man
looks defeated the Mongols this is not
the only defeat the Mongols ever
suffered by any means but it certainly
was a signal defeat because the the
Mongols never proceeded past that point
but nobody knew that was going to be the
result what they knew was that they had
defeated a Mongol army but not the main
Mongol army they had not defeated Hulagu
the ruler they didn't know when the
Mongols would come again but they were
fairly sure the Mongols would come again
so the two mammoth commanders who had
marched out of Cairo whose names were
kutas and by Mars they marched back
toward Cairo with their victorious
troops kutas never made it back and that
meant that Baibars
gets back to cairo becomes a sultan in
the year 1260 this is the beginning of
the mamluk dynasty or the Mamluk state
because from 1252 1260 it is ambiguous
exactly what the legitimacy is of the
Mamluks who are controlling things in
Cairo
but after 1260 the legitimacy is
established on the basis of their having
defeated the Mongols that legitimacy is
enhanced and extended in proportion to
the amount of fear of the Mongol return
that could be induced
so those people who wrote books under
Mameluke rule had a very very powerful
incentive to portray the mongols as the
the anti muslims the people under whom
you cannot live because they do not
understand or respect you know the
Sharia and so the Yassa
becomes this this horrible Specter that
you would have to live under the ASSA if
the Mongols ever came back
the Mongols in Iran come to an end with
the death of the last Mongol Sultan and
Iran in 1335 by that time the man looks
have been ruling in Egypt in Syria for
what 75 years they are well established
they continue to rule until 1516 when
the Ottoman out of an empire takes over
in Egypt and Syria and adds those
territories to Ottoman lands in what is
now Turkey and in Europe
so the map looks come into being and
their legitimacy as a state with
legitimacy based very heavily upon their
the fear of the Mongols but it would be
a mistake to simply look at them as as
people who were only mobilizing support
through the through the boogeyman
specter of another Mongol invasion that
is a part of it just as it's a part of
it in Lithuania part of it in
in Russia but it's by no means the only
story and this is where the problem of
structuring a book where the Mongols are
central and saying that the people whom
the Mongols come in contact are made
similar because of their reactions to
the Mongols this is where the problem
problem arises is that there there
really is a very different narrative
that you can adopt about the Mamluks
that does not replace but it certainly
accompanies this one this other
narrative I would say is largely based
on what happens with the pilgrimage in
other words the Mamluks inherit not only
rule in Egypt and Syria but they inherit
control of Mecca Medina and of course
Jerusalem not like that but there's no
longer any Calif in the Year 1258 or at
least there's no Calif in the generally
recognized sense in the year 1258 the
last Calif and Baghdad have been killed
for a two-year period until 1260 of the
Battle of iron jaw loot there had been
several people who were in one form or
another described or referred to as a
Calif like the ruler of Tunisia was the
minds of some people particularly
Tunisians a Calif the governor of Mecca
could be seen as a Calif but nobody had
any claim to being a Calif based on the
types of of credentials that the first
Calif that the Alliance and the
ambassador's of had nor did the Mamluks
have that kind of claim they weren't
even Arabs and the one thing that was
understood about the caliphate
was that the Caleb
should be an Arab in fact he should be a
member of the tribe of Quraish
Muhammad's tribe from Mecca there was
absolutely no way that among that the
Mamluks could qualify to be Kahless so
what they did in 1260 was what they
found a relative of the Dead Calif and
they put him on a throne in Cairo and
they said you're the Caleb and nobody
cared that Calif the so-called shadow
Caliphate lasts until the Ottoman
takeover in 1516 and there's no
persuasive record that the caliphs who
served during that time ever did
anything of note or commanded any broad
sense of loyalty or even that they
imparted any particular legitimacy to
the Mamluks
they appeared to be a kind of a sideshow
this may may be a distortion it may be
the Caleb's counted for more than they
appear but it's simply by contrast with
the failure of our the end of the
Abbasid Caliphate that they appear less
but the title that is most important for
the family is this title of the servant
of the two holy places they pour a lot
of investment into Mecca and Medina they
become heavily involved in Yemen and
they start to develop relations with the
southern part of the Muslim world I say
those people who live around the Indian
Ocean those people who live in the
interior of Africa
it's under the Mamluks following a humid
indication gestures that that Islam
spreads into the Sudan the frontier of
Islam had been pretty much of the
Egyptian Sudanese border for hundreds of
years according to a treaty that was
at the time of the conquest now Islam
under the Mamluks moves up the Nile
there is a a primacy that falls to the
pilgrimage to Mecca that if I were
redoing a world history I would put
great emphasis upon because in my view
to a large degree the pilgrimage to
Mecca and the control of the pilgrims
Mecca replaces the Caliphate as a
centralizing institution of the world
Muslim community say before 1100 it's
hard to even see that Mecca was much
more than just a small assemblage of of
buildings have a population of a few
thousand maybe five thousand if had
almost nothing in the way of services to
for visitors beyond what would be put up
temporarily for the pilgrimage itself
for the caravans when they came
but after Salah Hadean and even more
after the Mamluks and even more after
the ottomans Mecca Medina particular
Mecca become highly developed centers
and the pilgrimage which had been a
significant component of Islam ever
since the beginning but had never really
had much
much concrete substance I mean the
rituals of the pilgrimage were known he
went to Mecca you did certain rituals
you went home but that was pretty much
what it was now people go to Mecca for
that right now I mean from the 13th
century on they go to Mecca and they
frequently stay for 3 to 4 or 5 years
they study and they become indigent they
learn about Islam as it is practiced in
Arabia through their through their
pilgrimage and they learn who is the
most important figure in the Islamic
world in terms of who is that who
controls and provides support for the
pilgrimage the pilgrims who go to Mecca
Medina the symbol of this for the
Mamluks in Egyptian was their adoption
of a new ritual starting very early in
the Mamluk period can't remember the
exact year s of the 1260 s we have the
first indication of the use of what is
called the Mak mal the maqam al was a
camel saddle highly decorated as kind of
a of a you know a pavilion not a
pavilion a
the compartment that will be placed on
top of the camel if all sorts of
ornaments on it and it would be empty no
one would ride in the maqam al and the
Matabele would lead the caravan to to
Mecca before it departed from Egypt it
would tour Cairo and stop at the
residences of the major Mamluk rulers
and their be served blessings associated
with this and the maqam al becomes the
symbol of the Egyptian caravan nobody
knows at least from what I read where or
why the custom originated there have
been speculations it we do know that
there is a similar map al that existed
in nomadic tribes in Jordan and Syria in
the 20th century where a tribe when it
travelled would have a camel carrying an
ornamented saddle that would be empty
that just a an empty compartment some
people have said well that is the origin
of it of course it could be the other
way around it could be that the the
nomads Matabele is derived from the one
going to Mecca people have noted in
early Islamic history there was a famous
battle in which there was an empty horse
with an empty saddle who was supposed to
be there for no essentially for the
Messiah you know whether there is was
originally thought to be some sort of
spiritual specific spiritual content of
this is unknown but what we do know is
that other Muslim rulers decided they
should have a map
so you you would have a caravan would
show up from Egypt another one who'd
show up from say Afghanistan and each
would have a map now and then they'd
have a quarrel over which one gets to go
into Mecca first hmm
I like donkeys yes the donkey of the
Messiah and it was the primacy of the
Egyptian map now that was important the
math mail goes to Mecca every year down
until after World War one when the
Saudis take over in Mecca Medina and
bring the practice to an end so it's a
very important ritual and it is
something that is specific to the
mammoth period we don't know of it being
done under the Ayub it's something the
Mamluks thought up another thing that
happens at this time and we're dealing
here with the 1300s or very late 1200s
is that for the first time in Islamic
history people start to add to their
name a word that means pilgrim and that
word is either Hajji or
it always been possible for someone who
went of the pilgrimage which is called
the Hajj to say well I'm a Hajji I went
on the pilgrimage but nobody had ever
added it to their name I haven't found
anyone before 1,300 who has who's called
Hajji so and so after 1300 it becomes
extremely common and it is particularly
common in areas of sub-saharan Africa
India Southeast Asia but it's also
common in the Middle East it is
accompanied in different countries by
different rituals that have to do with
the honor that is earned by someone who
is a Hajji so someone who has gone on
the pilgrimage is now entitled to be
called Hajji he can now wear different
different clothes he can paint his door
green he can do certain things that
nobody else is allowed to do because
going on the pilgrimage imparts and an
honor within the Muslim context that had
not been there before and the pilgrimage
becomes in the absence or in the
aftermath of the caliphate
the pilgrimage becomes the place where
Muslims see their their connections
being formed most most strongly and in
later times people would make use of
contacts made in Mecca in ways that are
really quite quite instructive so you'll
have a pilgrim from China will meet a
pilgrim from Mecca hang out together in
Yemen go back to China and trance
Chinese Islam a pilgrim from Indonesia
will go to Mecca hang out for a few
years go back and change the way Islam
is recognized in Indonesia a pilgrim
from West Africa will go to Mecca
come back and change things there it
becomes the the center of the Islamic
world in in almost a literal sense and
there is nothing like it anywhere else
in the world this is very different from
say pilgrims going to Jerusalem or going
to Rome as Christians where there is a
long-standing custom but it doesn't have
a sort of collective impact in other
words if you make a pilgrimage to
Jerusalem you probably don't run into
you know Ethiopians and Indians and you
know Christians from far far away you
may and I don't know of any instance of
this well one of the indications that
the Muslim pilgrimage is the the model
is the the most important one is that
Christians after 1300 but I don't know
exactly when we start to call themselves
Hajji if they make the pilgrimage to
Jerusalem so you have Greeks and
Serbians who will add Haji to their name
because they made a pilgrimage to
Jerusalem Hajis an Arabic word the Hajj
refers to going to Mecca not going to
Jerusalem but the notion that pilgrimage
deserves to be a part of your of your
identity carries over into the Eastern
Christian communities that does not
carry over into Western Europe I don't
know of anyone in Western Europe who is
called Hajji but but there are Greeks
who were certainly called Hajji often it
shows up today
in in last names like Hadji Constantino
or Hadji Demetrio or Hadji incio or
something like that and you run into
Greeks who have these names there are
some Jews who come to recall who who
have Haji to their name after they have
visited Jerusalem in other words the the
primacy given to the pilgrimage in this
BAM luke era or the post salahuddin era
affects not only the Muslim world but it
affects the notion of what of what's so
journeying in a sacred place is all
about even for non-muslims to me this is
a really great story in world history
the reason I've given so much time to it
also I give a lot of time to it because
I've been studying him I need to talk
about what you know but but to me this
is kind of the essence of what of a
story that really is important for world
history because it affects Muslims
everywhere in the world in this period
after the fall the Caliphate and the
other story that still has not found a
historian there is a good book on the
history of the pilgrimage and the
Ottoman Empire by certain Serrano farouq
farouq II although that concentrates on
me it shows how important the pilgrimage
is for the Ottomans but it concentrates
on the sort of the the Ottoman dimension
of it without looking at the much
broader dimensions I've been trying to
stress here the pilgrimage so far as I
can tell doesn't have a thing to do with
the Mongols
now if you are going to to look at this
Mameluke phenomenon and say you know as
a state slave warriors who become the
essentially the rulers of a state that
they have no champ challenge from anyone
else you're going to say which is more
important the fear of the Mongols that
undoubtedly was real following the
Battle of I'm John boutt or the
fostering of a new institutional and
ritual emphasis in the Muslim religion
which would be more important I'm I'm
really not sure but I think that over
the long term the more important one
would be would be the pilgrimage but you
can't get there from a starting point
that says that it is fear of the month
fear of the Mongols or the influence of
the Mongols or the presence of the
models that is your main the main
shaping force in world history at this
time in the in the broad comparison I
started with where people look at the
era of the Mongols from basically the
1200s and into the early 1300s when they
look at this era and they say let's
think of this in comparison with the
European voyages of discovery a topic
we'll talk about at the very end of this
course you can legitimately ask a
question of well is it really comparable
because the voyages of discovery were
followed by huge changes in the world
that affected pretty much every part of
the world for hundreds of years the
Mongol invasions
create an empire but by 1350 it was kind
of game over not only for the Mongol
Empire but Central Asia never again
becomes the center of world history you
could probably make an argument that
starting with the Silk Road in 300 BC
perhaps even earlier and up to the
period of the Mongols ending around say
1300 or so ad then if 1600 years during
which Central Asia and the transfer of
ideas and goods and political ideas and
so forth across Central Asia that this
plays a central role in world history
and then you would probably have to say
that that comes to an end with the
Mongols and that maybe they should be
known not so much as the people who
destroyed all the cities but the people
who destroyed you know Eurasian Eurasian
contacts that they're kind of ironically
credited with having having built up
because you you know I'm leaving out
tamerlane out tamerlane comes along he
briefly holds things together he dies in
1405 end of the story for Tamerlane but
but by largest with the mongols that
this that this whole Central Asian
business comes to an end and after that
it's maritime contacts that are the
dominant ones world history so we have
in in my book we have contributed to the
the re-evaluation of the Mongols in
their role in world history and I think
it's a really bad can legitimately be
queried not not tonight I mean that the
Mongols are important
think is you know is not deniable but
what they're important for and whether
we should see the 13th century is
pivoting around the Mongols as opposed
to around other things for Egypt in
Syria the pilgrimage for Russia
Lithuania perhaps something else for
Japan as we'll see on Thursday perhaps
other things entirely it may be that
we've gone too far in rehabilitating the
Mongols or or that we have stopped short
of asking all of the pertinent questions
about the role that they played in world
history that's something really kind of
populist in that anyway might as well
stop there